[Music]
good to see you my friend thank you for
driving all the way out here my pleasure
thanks for wanna do this for a long time
known each other for many years I for
some reason I thought it was seven or
eight but we were talking before the
podcast I guess it's been like 10 years
yes
not that we're hanging out all the time
you pop in from time to time well we
have a lot of we have a lot of mutual
friends and and and mutual uh you know
we're both on this planet so that's
right we are on the spinning blue globe
together we're all in it together we are
we are and it's just been so cool to see
you know this this evolution of your
career I mean you know my lord like you
know not that you weren't working
constantly before Bosch because you have
the longest IMDB and like the history of
acting but uh you know Bosch is really
for stood you into you know the
mainstream as this leading man and like
such a prominent way I mean I can't go
anywhere without seeing a massive
billboard they do they crazy they do
their job
that's probably unsettling for a lot of
people to certainly my enemies would
find out are you kids like oh my god
everywhere I go my dad is staring down
at me yeah they don't you know and I
make a conscious effort when when the
show cuz the billboards typically come
out a couple weeks before the show comes
on mm-hmm and they you know every major
city they're on the sides of buildings
and here in Hollywood so I make a
conscious effort of avoiding areas with
us because God forbid I do a Times
Square yeah I don't want to be seen
within proximity of one of my billboards
because I know somebody will drive by
and go like what a what a self-serving
as if it was your idea yeah but you know
the good thing is that you can't go in
and out of LAX without seeing the big
billboards they really do their job of
you know publicizing getting the word
out there uh-huh about the show sewn
that way I'm you know I'm eternally
eternally grateful for that
well you must have good relationships
with cops these days yeah you know
customs agent like anybody who's you
know in sort of some form of law
enforcement yeah you get a pass you
could pull have you been pulled over and
no fortunately I have and the one thing
I do have is quite often as the cops
will roll up on me and their patrol cars
when I'm driving and say hello not you
know there and you know the nice thing
about that I mean I've always kind of
played a lot of cops in my career from
different cities and places and yeah and
growing up had had friends who became
cops and I've always kind of had that
connection to to law enforcement and
they're very supportive of the show and
I think one of the you know long before
we ever did the show the the books were
extremely successful and I think part of
which speaks to that is the fact that
particularly with the show
it's very grounded in reality you know I
don't drive a Porsche and and I don't
have you know I'm not like James Bond
jumping it out of bed with all these
with different women and you got a cool
house though he's got a cool house he
has the the very cool house and of
course that that's sort of the great
metaphor of being kind of the Eagles
Nest for a guy who is surveying and
surveying the city and all that's good
and bad in it but cops like it because
it's it's no it's no nonsense and I've
even said two cops God you know this is
what you do for a living so I can't
imagine that after a day of being you
know a robbery homicide detective seeing
the worst of the worst in the world that
you you you want to go home and and you
know and crack a beer and a bag of chips
and put your feet up and watch a
procedural law drama but the thing is
that our show really it's not like Law &
Order it doesn't have the thing where
Bosh kind of catches the case at the
beginning works the case through the
middle of the show and then gets the bad
guy by the end I mean we have ten
episodes there are novels yeah and so
that's just the the structure of the
show the narrative is much more like
reading a novel you know each episode
really serves more as a purpose of being
like a chapter in a book you know and we
all ingest literature at different paces
and in the same way I think now with
this whole binge-watching notion see as
little or as much as you want
and there are certain things that I'll
watch where as much as I want to want to
get through it because it's so good I
really try to kind of save or sometimes
yeah yeah I mean stranger things was for
me was so difficult because it was so
engaging that I couldn't pull away from
right you wanted his rip through it want
to want to go through it but then you
know if I would do more than two
episodes I was you know I was like a bad
kid that ate too much cake and then
right then I feel kind of shamed which
of course you know speaks to me I I like
that immersive experience you know and I
really prefer the kind of shows that
unfurl themselves slowly and take their
time and I will go so far as to four
shows that aren't all online at the same
time where they you know eat them out
week by week I'll wait until the
season's over I didn't start it because
I don't want to wait a week and then
forget what happened you have to reboot
myself to get into it again so it is
like reading a book yeah no I do I do
that the same way but if it's a there's
certain Network shows that my daughter
and I you know will watch together and
that's sort of the you know and then you
can can come on then you can watch it on
righthand when you want to but anything
that's on Amazon or Netflix or Hulu
that's that doesn't come out drop all at
once I'll wait and I'll just wait
because I want to be able to have that
choice right which is I mean you know
it's we live in the Society of serious
attention-deficit yeah and impatience
but that's okay right
well the unanimous consensus is that you
know never has there been a character
that fit an actor more like a glove than
Hieronymus Bosch with you you know even
so far as you know Stephen King you know
publicly saying and on Twitter I mean
this is like everybody sees you so
closely identified with this character
from these many books that Michael
Connelly wrote I mean how do you know
how do you approach that like how did
you figure out how to inhabit that
person with that
level of authenticity well there's
there's always the the sort of
background you know research cop stuff
how to get in and out of the car and
weapons handling and you spend a ton of
time I mean over your career you've
played enough cops at that part of it
was kind of there but the thing that
hooked me into this character was the
the humanity of him I mean you know he's
not he's a wheel he's a he's an antihero
you know he's a quintessential antihero
he's he's flawed there's a there's a
profound kind of sadness to the
character there are definitely certain
similarities in that way that made that
character that I responded to him
because I saw him as a vulnerable you
know a strong guy with a really good
moral compass but but a person who's
kind of broken to a certain degree and I
think that I identify with that because
I'm I'm broken to a certain degree I
sustained a lot of you know personal
tragedy in my life and so I understand
that you know that that loss and how and
how you navigate that now how I navigate
it and how Harry has navigated it are
two very very different things but I
understand it and so I think that
enabled me to have a real bead on on
write who who he is but I've heard you
say that you you know you tried not to
bring yourself to a character because
that's not acting but inevitably given
you know we're gonna talk about you know
your you know your history and all of
that but you know your life experience
informs how you're gonna you know
inhabit this person well no I and I
guess to clarify that it's more of as an
actor what I learned early on when I was
particularly studying the method at the
Strasbourg Institute was that to use
experiences from my from my own life to
sort of move myself in that direction
performance wise and then to try to
perform was that all that I alt
li was doing was I was reliving a very
painful memory and then when I would try
to act I was so completely detached from
the character and and and so connected
to my own personal pain that I didn't
feel like I was acting and it felt it
didn't feel safe to me it didn't feel
good to me and not that all acting has
to be safe I mean I think it's about you
know stepping out and taking certain
risks but then again I think risk in
acting is a very you know misused word
because it's acting right it's pretend I
mean what is that
so if your risk is in the vulnerability
exactly but I think you know if you're
playing a guy who's got a broken arm you
don't need to go slam go break your arm
so that you understand uh-huh that you
can you can or playing a character
that's overweight you know I've done
that I've gained like 65 pounds for a
role and that's a different thing part
of it was because I knew that with that
weight that I was going to move
differently that I would breathe
differently that I would certainly look
different and of course I was young when
I did that huh I would I would be less
inclined to do some kind of a crazy well
at my age it's a little bit stupid to
put on 65 all right yeah I could do it
but God you rocking a huge beard right
yeah well that's my that's all the
that's the weight I've gained but I I
found that early on that that it wasn't
something that was really servicing me
as an actor and then I met David Mamet
the playwright and I studied with him
and something that I learned from him is
the process which he's sort of his
technique for lack of a better word was
kind of a bastardized version of the
Sanford Meisner thing and but within
that you rather than taking something
from your own personal life experience
you would create and as if scenario
as it relates to the action of what the
characters are literally doing on the
page and I found that that serviced me
really well and consistently in
performing because that's what it's
about I mean there's always the worry
you're doing you're doing a play or
something which is you know obviously
it's a very different medium than film
but you you arrive at that place where
you know the king has been killed and
you have to mourn him and you know where
how do you arrive at that place every
night where and and what I kind of
realized was that you know to to
demonstrate emotion certainly pain and
anguish didn't necessarily have to
translate as tears which you know
presented a whole new bunch of questions
for me as an actor and I just find also
that when the writing is really good and
when you're working with a cross-table
from another actor and and that that
focus and concentration is on each other
it is sort of take the attention off
yourself and put it on the other person
and the writing is good the you don't
have to necessarily work as hard you
know it becomes it sort of happens
organically to a certain degree because
you just kind of invest in that moment
in these imaginary circumstances and
they they kind of have their own life
right you still have you have control
over it but it that's just for me I have
young friends who are deeply steeped in
in the method world and and they work
that way and they navigate it really
well I got the exhaust thing now yeah I
mean under any circumstances when you
put you know because people say to me oh
when you come home after a day of
working on Bosch you know you are you
depressed and I say no because I'm I'm
acting I'm able to separate that now is
the material heavy are there scenes that
are harder to play than others
particularly when they within
circumstances of dealing with tragedy
sure but I you know I don't carry that
necessarily home it affects me in the
moment when I'm I'm playing the scene
but I'm not I'm not dragging my feet
when I come home because
had to shoot a scene where I'm doing a
you know notification a death
notification to to a victim's family
right were you part of mammoths Theatre
Company I well my all my classmates were
where they I I don't know I was always
one of those guys that wasn't big on
clubs and things like that yeah
and I that whole thing was kind of
birthed out of one of mammoths he had a
great knack for throwing challenges out
and because we were all sort of eager to
please he said one day who in here wants
to start a theater company and who wants
to write a book about this technique so
everybody shot their hands up and I I
might have been the only one who just
sort of kept my hands on my lap because
my thing was there were a couple of
companies that came out of my ear there
was the Atlantic Theatre Company with
Mamet and then there was the naked
angels company that also came out of
there and these were we were all in the
same class and my thing was that I was
really interested in doing the work as
an actor and working with these
companies but I didn't I'm not a
political person and I so I didn't want
to be involved with that process of
decision making I'm the kind of
infighting that goes in and power
struggles and things I'm not interested
in that I just I like to show up and and
do my thing and and be and not be a part
of that right but what didn't I mean it
had to be amazing though at the early
stages of that to be with Mamet I mean
you've worked with some amazing writers
but to be with a master and develop that
appreciation and respect for the written
text when well done well that that
completely it's not that I didn't have
respect for writers before that but it
it gave me an opportunity and and then
the tools to really have a different
understanding of the process as an actor
when you're interacting with the writing
and how to to me I felt like it became
sort of a personal challenge and then to
go from working with Mamet to working
with
another great writer like David Milch it
it really informed a lot about how I
wanted to act and how I wanted to relate
to writers and also the the protection
of of the writing but also the challenge
of trying to beat the page I always sort
of feel like when somebody puts a great
piece of writing in front of you as an
actor it's kind of your job to not only
facilitate the the the writers vision to
the best of your ability but to kind of
get in there and kind of kick its ass a
little bit at the same time and maybe do
something bring some nuance to that that
the writer might never have considered
in terms of language or like inflection
like how your intention
yeah intention of or how to to
demonstrate the writers intention by
kind of making it your own right and
I've had those moments and those are
those are really winning moments where
I've been doing something with David and
you know would complete a scene and and
and have David you know milk say you
know I didn't consider you know I didn't
consider this or I didn't consider that
what made you think of personal victory
yeah yeah and it is but it's also
becomes then it feels more like a
collaboration and I certainly have that
on Bosh with with Tom Bernardo and Eric
Overmeyer and Daniel Pine and and all
these great writers and of course
Michael Connelly I mean the center of it
all any any kind of Bosh questions that
have ever come up or ideas I always
would run them up the flagpole with
Michael and discuss them
is this something a place that we can go
does this does this resonate does this
seem like Bosh and he you know now that
being said I didn't feel like I needed
to to make gigantic changes to this
character there were just some little
things to make it a little bit more
personal in my interpretation because we
already had
Changez age and things like that and we
don't you know we don't follow the books
chronologically so we kind of move all
over the place mm-hmm and Michael's has
always been really receptive to that and
and and there's no there's no ego it's
not ego driven in that way you know I
mean and I've come up with things where
he's he said I like that idea but I
don't it doesn't seem like like a hairy
thing uh-huh fortunately it hasn't been
all that often but I'm also not going to
him all the time and saying you know why
can't can he drive a black Porsche you
know and where leisure suits and I don't
know where that came from but things I
feel germane to something that that Bosh
would do yeah and the and the Harry of
the show is you know my the thing that
I've always helped fast - no pun
intended was to really maintain the
Tegrity and the integrity and the core
of who that character is in the books
because he's so perfectly realized and I
get to the point now where there'll be
certain bits of dialogue that will come
across in scripts and and I'll I'll
tweak it because to me mm-hmm it's well
it might be a great piece of dialogue in
that moment there's just things that
somebody being moved around a little bit
in order for it to feel like it it's
coming out of his mouth this could go on
forever
I mean Connolly you know is so prolific
what he's written like 32 novels or
something how many is like 20 was 21 I
believe right books I mean you can a new
one come this could just be you know go
on ad infinitum when you're going into
season six season six when do you start
shooting I searched shooting that in
August uh-huh but you know Mike said
recently somebody asked him I don't
remember where the the question popped
up but asked him how how long how much
longer how many more box box he'll write
because now he's brought in this new
character this other detective Renee
Ballard and and she's younger
Harry's retired and so now he's
combining
these characters are inhabiting each
other's world but they're doing it kind
of sunrise pain oh yeah
so it'll be interesting I mean look if
if Mike stopped writing bosh books
tomorrow and we were going into season
20 or whatever there that character so
well established now that the writers
and they do anyway
mm-hmm you know they are able to sort of
within the the Bosch universe that's
been created they can you know they they
come up with ideas that literally a
franchise yeah you know it's
unbelievable
well what I'm interested in it I mean
look you've worked with essentially
everybody in the business over the
course of your career but the roles that
have really defined you at least from
you know my outside perspective relate
to filmmakers writers creators with whom
you've developed almost this mentor you
know relationship or Co collaborator
relationship like whether it's Milch
you've done all of Ben Affleck's movies
now Connolly like what is the
distinguished like what distinguishes
like these great minds these prolific
creators from other people that you work
with and you know why these guys like
why do you have this more intimate
relationship with some filmmakers other
than others well I think I got I've just
been very fortunate in that way and then
I've come into contact with people that
you know maybe on some level were we're
kindred spirits for for lack of a better
word you know and some of that just
happened or are almost questions that
are difficult for me to answer there
they do have to ask that they'd have to
ask them what is it that that they see I
suppose part of it is I'm really
dedicated to to to what I do and also as
for writers I'm very dedicated just to
servicing the writing because I
understand it so it's not just about me
showing up and and learning my lines
I've never I've never approached it that
way and it's not like I come in like a
bull in a china shop and say okay I'm
here now so
let me completely reconfigure what
you've established here and I like to
think it's because I have a modicum of
intelligence and and these people
recognize also that I have a good work
ethic and if anything I I strive to make
things better you know I'm not a big
believer in coming in and being
pedestrian because that's my face on the
screen and I don't want to half-ass
anything yeah well there's there's
talent there's ability and that will
take you to a certain place but then
people want to work with people they
like that they feel safe with that they
feel like they can get along with over
the long haul I would imagine yeah and
it's not to say that um that I've not in
working with those people that I've not
had disagreements about things but
there's a there's a foundation of
respect there's a foundation of respect
and there's also a way to it never has
it's never been a power struggle it's
always been a thing of and I suppose
there's there's at times that I sort of
present these things to them and say you
know right wrong or indifferent I have
this idea and that it's considered you
know what I mean with respect I mean I
there were times the things with with
Milch where I I would come up with
something in milk would say you know
that's a great idea
but not for this show but it's a but
it's a great idea and and I accept that
with equanimity because for me I'm also
despite the fact that I'm 57 years old I
feel like I'm I'm in a constant state of
you know evolution as you know as an
artist and so I always sort of I never
want to give myself a break I want to be
challenged and I want to I want to get
better at what I do and and the older I
get I I think that I've figured some
things out to a certain degree I
certainly know as an actor what what
things work for me technique-wise
and you know I'm not an actor who does
multiple
of things I'm just I can't work that way
I don't run up to something I come in
I'm prepared
I make certain choices prior to shooting
if I have questions or things I would
discuss it with the director or the
writer but that being said when I come
in
I'm not intractable you know I also like
to see what's gonna happen you know in
the moment in the room with another
actor so I I don't I never marry myself
wholeheartedly to an idea because I I
just find that that makes it kind of
stagnant
do you do you like rehearsal you seem
like a guy who wants to who's more in
favor of being present to the magic yeah
I I mean the rehearsal process certainly
in theatre is is absolutely necessary
right it's a whole different different
animal the technical aspect of film and
television is a is a very different way
of working and so I tend to with with in
film and television I don't like to
rehearse III I like to rehearse for
camera so that you can kind of say well
I'm gonna I'm gonna sit here or I might
get up or etc etc so that the you don't
have to do it again yeah the direct the
cinematographer has a sense in the and
the director is saying you know then
they can come back and go oh I really
you know I wasn't
I didn't visualize you sitting for this
whole thing and then you kind of bandy
that about but as far as rehearsing
rehearsing I mean I I don't mind
technical rehearsals but I don't wanna I
don't want to sit down and do a series
of rehearsals before we shoot because I
feel like that kind of that that bleeds
the
the authenticity out of it and it makes
people self-conscious and then they they
really start acting and then it has a
very very different feel to get locked
they get a closed mindset this is what
I'm gonna do right now and then you see
them when
when you know they'll do something in a
master and you can always tell you know
within the master shot they'll do this
one particular thing and I immediately I
get cluded and I go that's the red flag
day that's they've got that that's their
thing for this and you don't what you
don't want our nasty things well you
don't want to interfere in another
person's process or be disrespectful to
that that's when it becomes a little bit
tricky because you have to be sensitive
to to the other to the other actor but
also you know as a lead on a show and a
producer on a show when you see
something that doesn't ring right you
know totally within the scene you see
somebody make a choice that's really
really broad and doesn't necessarily
help tell the story because I always say
hey look if you're gonna make a choice
make a choice that's gonna help tell the
story because it's very easy to get and
would look when you're mean when I when
I wasn't all the attention to my so I
was I was all about business and you
know I'm gonna eat peanuts here and I'm
gonna drink the beer and I'm gonna smoke
a cigarette and you know I'm gonna clean
my gun and you know and what I realize
is I got older was I didn't have to do
all that [ __ ] you know it if it wasn't
telling the story it just was business
and so now I'm terrible like you know
directors will come in and go yeah you
know might be maybe you're making
yourself a cup of coffee and I'd say why
I you know I the characters already had
his cup of coffee but there's a
stillness to Bosch too and the proximity
of the camera you know lends itself to
subtlety and that's by design I mean
when I read when I read the script one
of the first things then I felt about
that character was it he was that there
was a great power and his stillness it
was a guy who didn't necessarily
subscribe to the societal norms that you
and I do eat is not a guy who walks into
a room and wants to win the day you know
he doesn't give a [ __ ] what and he
doesn't thinks about and it's not that
he's that he's a prick or he's or that
he's a bad guy he just has uh
mitad patience for he's unapologetic
about Yahoo he is and I and there's
something kind of interesting and
refreshing about someone who comes in
because there are also times when he
sticks his elbows out but I felt a real
I felt that I gravitated towards the
stillness of that character because
really when you read the books and when
you know he's he's an observer he's a
guy who's in a constant state of
observation and also a guy who doesn't
want to draw attention to himself so you
know and that's difficult stuff to act
to a certain degree and also when you
consider that the a lot of stuff that's
going on internally with Bosch when you
you you have the luxury of the of the
narrative to for the reader to be able
to say this is what's going on in his
head he's doing that but so but how do
you translate yeah without it's without
the kind of noir trope of using a lot of
voiceover right which we don't do I mean
I remember one point somebody making a
joke early on and I thought they were
serious when they said yeah maybe the
voice-over thing and I just yeah I want
that be okay if we were doing like a
1940s 1950s yeah then you you do that
and you establish that and that's okay
but this is neo noir and so my thought
in particularly in these moments in the
show where you'll find Harry by himself
looking over a murder book or being
contemplative or just observing the city
you know I I treasure those moments
because it those moments really
challenged me in that I've got to in
some way project some internal life and
some you know inner emotional life with
this character without without dialogue
right and you know how you manifest that
in your physicality and I think that
that comes through not only the
relationship to being still but also
having you know
- great cinematographers that know you
know we've now been doing this going
into six years they know how I work then
we're wearing and where it's gonna come
not necessarily when and it becomes
about where they're moving the camera to
kind of arrive at that place to find
Harry and and you know I I have people
with some frequency say that to me that
they they like they really like those
moms they go I know I know you're not
saying anything but there's a lot they
read it they wrote their fans of the
book to they can purge it your there's a
there's a blackness upon which they can
project their idea Bosh right which is
you know and you have little secret like
you have little secrets to or techniques
like I've read or heard you say so at
some point like when Harry doesn't like
somebody he looks at his he looks at the
person's forehead and like tiny little
things that you can rely on that the
audience might not be consciously aware
of but feed that character Sensibility
yeah well there's a lot you know 22
because there's a lot of there's there's
the Harry in the books and then and and
my interpretation of that Harry and the
books and then personality traits of
male figures who who have influenced me
my father being one of them
warts in all and David Milch men who
have had who have had influence right
and I both like hard-boiled guys yeah
kind of no-nonsense hard but but also
very sensitive and and vulnerable men I
mean there's a lot of what's that weird
combination of artists sensibility with
like traditional kind of values about
hard work and and not taking any [ __ ]
from anybody right and I think also
that's what makes him what what makes
Harry good at his job is that he's not a
guy who would ever bend the rules and
certainly ethically he's not gonna beat
a confession out of out of a suspect and
he's not gonna plant evidence on someone
to gain a conviction you know there's
that kind of dogged pursuit of justice
and he really
is that guy who who is the advocate for
the victim and for the victim's family
and there's a there was a great line and
we've repeated it since then we're
people of you know referenced closure
and Bosh says closures a myth you know
because that's and that's true well that
was the arc of the season of solving you
know your wife's murder right yeah that
he arrives at that place of solving it
to realize that the closure didn't carry
the meaning that he was searching for
and and and also the you know finally
figuring out who was that that that
killed his mother that that it was empty
ultimately right his mother that's what
I meant and that he couldn't yes that he
couldn't really reconcile that right I
mean there's a part of him that sort of
is able to to close that chapter you
know in his in his history but but the
damage and and the pain is is something
that you know he'll you know I don't
think the people ever can outlive that
that pain you know to to assuage their
their pain you can you just you find a
place to be able to navigate that so
that you can get out of bed in the
morning and that you can be a productive
person in life but that pain was you
know imagine no you know a
thirteen-year-old kid his mother's
murdered you know and and and that's the
that's the impetus for him to because
nobody gave a [ __ ] because his mother
was a prostitute and so the effort into
solving her murder was to a lesser
degree which hence you have Harry's
thing everybody counts her nobody counts
and you know that's uh that's a that's a
big that's a big load and he carries
that I mean that's the thing also with
it there there is a world weariness with
Harry and what we've been able to do is
that through his relationship with his
daughter and those are scenes that I
probably treasure the most of all the
scenes that I do on that show is working
with Matt
and Lintz I mean a I'm a father I
understand but I'm also not Harry Bosch
so I I have I have been in my children's
lives right whereas he was kind of an
absentee parent and now he's thrust into
the world of being a parent and being
present and figuring out how to navigate
and be a parent when he doesn't he
doesn't have any skills you know but it
softens him it does and I think it's
made him it's it for the first time in
his life I think you see a guy who's
who's allowing himself to trust
happiness a little bit uh-huh because
that's the one thing that I I've carried
as a through-line
with Bosch and people say what is he
about and I say and what is that you
connect with and I said I can i connect
and understand that thing I'm not trust
in happiness when you when you are dealt
a body blow like that that's that's what
it becomes and I feel that that Maddie's
presence in his life and now more than
ever with Eleanor having been killed
that they're that they're together that
he's he's trusting happiness and I'm and
it doesn't change him from his way of
pursuing justice for victims and and I
guess ya softened him a bit and yet by
the same token there's this there's an
internal kind of terror that exists
inside of him in in caring for his
daughter he wants to he wants to protect
her from from all this stuff in the
world he's trying to imbue her with some
sense of awareness and some time to the
point where it's smothering for her and
she's kind of saying hey hey pushing
back she pushes back but she's also his
daughter and she's a strong woman young
woman so there's a lot of him in her
which he recognizes but that also scares
him you know a while while he's he's
happy to see her her development
he's also repelled by it
it scares him because he sees the path
laid forward for her in a way that's too
close to his own yeah yeah yeah well
it's been fun watching the show over the
years you know this inextricable
relationship connection between Los
Angeles and that you know the sort of
tradition of noir from Chandler and now
you know in the embodiment of Connolly's
work but I've always you know enjoyed
those movies and books at arm's length
as somebody who's lived in Los Angeles
for you know a couple decades yeah
because you know we're out here in
Calabasas you know I lived on the always
lived west side and the Los Angeles
portrayed in those works and in Bosch
was always a Los Angeles that I just
didn't recognize at all I'm like how
it's like this mythic you know at times
antiquated picture of this city that I
live in but I've had this recent
experience where my 15 year old daughter
is now in art school which I want to
talk to you yeah she goes to this school
that's east of downtown and so we've
rented an apartment in downtown LA
because it's too far to drive from out
here my wife and I take turns staying
down there with her so I've been
spending all this time I spent half a
week in downtown now I'm running around
MacArthur Park in Boyle Heights I'm you
know meeting a friend at a wood-paneled
restaurant with you know red leather you
know banquet booths in I'm like this is
the noir la that I see depicted and all
this working I've had moments where I'm
like oh this is where a boss would you
know yeah meet his buddies for a drink
absolutely that la exists and Los
Angeles is very strange in that your
lifestyle is defined by the neighborhood
you know the 5-mile radius in which you
live and there's a whole other world
going on you know just a couple miles
away yeah that's very different place
with people who are inhabiting lives
that resemble the lodge portrayed on the
show yeah well we're there I mean you
know that's the thing the you know Harry
Bosch land he works Hollywood homicide
so yeah that's where he is he's down
tonight he's in Boyle Heights he's in
all these
these places and then you have Hollywood
and of course you know it's the great
sort of metaphors it is it's the
Boulevard of broken dreams you know you
see all these and that's the thing that
always sort of intrigued me was the idea
that all these people who came out here
with with you know hopes of fame and
fortune and and the endless tales of
people who come out and then just kind
of disappear right when it doesn't
happen they disappear that go down these
bad roads and there there are all these
nefarious characters who who prey on
these people
and and that's sort of the you know
that's the thing it's the facade it's
like going to a back lot on on Warner
Brothers who Universal and you see you
know you're in you're in Europe you know
and University oh my god you know these
cobblestone streets and then you you
know you walk around and there's you
know four by sixes and things that are
propping up these these these facades
and they're and there's a lot of that
here because there's so much it's so
enticing in that way to a certain degree
to people they look at it and it's
everybody's everybody's rich and
everybody's famous and no they're not
you know and then you you know you walk
down Holly wal Hollywood Boulevard
you know after eight o'clock at night or
and even now so I mean no matter how
much they try to clean it up and make it
different it's like downtown it's the
same ain't broken it's broken you see
you know people refer to the zombie
apocalypse and I say these aren't these
aren't zombies these are people that
have that have been discarded by society
that through that that are either
mentally ill or they've been or have
lost their jobs and or have you know
chemical dependency issues and things
like that or you know nobody and manin
because particularly when I hear these
aren't necessarily people that I know
because I don't associate with people
who think that way but the idea that
these discarded people are just kind of
zombies and oh well you know the only
way to
turned downtown into its own sort of you
know Emerald City is to get rid of all
the homeless people and clean it all up
and then it'll all be fine and then
things will thrive down there well you
know the downtown is has found a way to
thrive yeah you know it's there I have
lots of friends who spend time there I
didn't mean I you know and go and and
eat in restaurants down there I've never
really had a connection there until
until I was shooting down there all the
time and it's uh you know it it saddens
me but it's sort of like the the more
they try to just slap a coat of paint on
it it feels to me that it sort of
exacerbates yeah I think it is just
moments the problem yeah you know I've
had some interesting experiences because
I live you know our place is really
close to Skid Row and I'll go running in
the morning and I'll purposely run
through Skid Row because I just I want
to you know I want to have the visceral
experience of what's actually going I've
done stuff with that community in the
past but what I've noticed is that I
never feel unsafe running through they
know I don't either
you know to to you know an observant eye
it looks dangerous he says I mean for
people that don't know it's literally a
tent city it is on for like you know
it's a square mile
looks like Bangladesh yeah basically a
third-world country right in downtown
Los Angeles and I'll go run right down
the middle of the street and you know I
get nothing but smiles and waves and hey
how you doing and keep going like way
friendlier than the people up on the
trail right here yeah and there's a
sense of community and connectivity that
those people have you know amidst this
tremendous despair you know this
impoverished state in which they live
and it's it's a horrific sight and yet
there's an inescapable like heart and
humanity to it well it's it's you know
it it's a part of the ugly reality right
that we look around and we see people
families living inside of tents and
they're not all these are not indigent
people that have you know have ruined
their lives with alcohol
drugs or what have you or these are
people who have lost their jobs who have
worked at places and have busted their
asses for years and years only to be
told hey we're downsizing the job that
you did is being outsourced to a robot
or two to Pakistan or or what have you
like we shoot down there a lot so I've
had a lot of interaction with with
people there and met some really
wonderful and interesting people who who
have incredible stories to tell and we
you know because we go into these
environments as this as a big Hollywood
production and yet we have we have
executive producers who are human beings
who recognize that we are sort of
inflicting ourselves to a certain degree
on this place to sort of capture this
for entertainment and so you know
there's always extra food brought along
mmm cases of water and things like that
I mean these are small gestures we can't
go in and and and solve the the the ills
of society but I've I've had a lot of
interaction with people and they're very
funny because they've a lot of these
people have seen me in in films and
television shows and things and then one
of the first times he went down to the
to the bins where almost people will put
their things in these storage bins and
we were shooting there the idea that I
was interacting with them several of
them were kind of vexed by it
well our you know you're a big star and
I say well first of all I'm not a big
star I'm a working actor but you know
but you're talking to people and I say
but you know why wouldn't I and then and
was felt kind of saddened by that and
yet once once the people realize that I
was not that that guy but was just a you
know there are people that I kind of I
see the same people sometimes and he'll
come down and hey how you doing and
editor Don
and interacting and and yeah I don't
feel unsafe when I'm down there I feel
quite the opposite I feel like it's it's
people just trying to live you know live
in really harsh circumstances but but
just trying to to live with some dignity
I I don't know what the solution is but
whatever we're doing right now is not
working no it's not working now it's
it's not working at all and and and you
know in a barge out into the middle of
the ocean which we always sort of joke
that's what happened to New York um you
know I had moved out of New York and
then I came back two years later and was
saying to my brother where are all the
for all the homeless people where are
these people that and you do you know
particularly within a neighborhood
scenario you sort forged these
relationships particularly with a lot of
people that would that would in New York
that were mentally ill yet when they
were teaming it takes care of them a
neighborhood takes care of them you know
and also says hey you know please don't
don't pee on the doorstep right you know
I I just always think of my mother who
would you know our leftover food never
went into the fridge through a
refrigerator my mother would put it into
baggies and things and she would you
know it always made me nervous but she
would would go out and if she didn't
find any people to give the food to she
would write a note you know and place it
in a plate where it would you know and I
would say this is good food and I was
raised that way and then that you
extended yourself and a lot of times
particularly you know people who weren't
from my neighbor when I would go out in
in in the world and my neighborhood and
and people that I was with would see how
I would interact and they would go to I
was really crazy and I would say he
anybody doesn't mean any harm
yeah he just you have these
conversations with him and I said he's a
human being it's not his fault item a
and I'm not threatened by him I can tell
when he's if he's just come out of a
long stay you know at Bellevue because
he's you know his clothes or and so I
you know he's slightly less disheveled
he looks cleaner and and he's got a base
because he's but I you know I say you
know then within a couple weeks he's
gonna be shouting at people on the
street because he's not getting us
medication since in things like well
when you're in New York when you live in
New York for any extended period of time
you develop that like radar like you can
tell the difference between someone
who's dangerous yeah and someone who's
you know neutral and not a threat and
there's all those cues that you just
into it into your life yeah you know but
let's take it back to your background I
mean you had an incredibly interesting
eclectic childhood raised by two artists
yeah it was I could I guess he would say
it was somewhat rarefied although to me
it was normal because all the kids that
you know I grew up surrounded by by
painters and poets and illustrators and
musicians and film directors and
screenwriters and sculptors and so we
were all kind of being the children of
these people we were kind of latchkey
kids in the art world and and so to us
that made a lot of sense it was when we
sort of strayed from outside of that
which was familiar to us and somebody
would say oh what are your parents do
and I would say they're artists all
right you know I've ever seen - it could
oh my dad's a painter and he said oh and
my dad oh well my dad wants to paint our
house maybe kahan and then sort of
explain kind of difficult for them to
wrap their their minds around and but
and I think in in that you know people
say well obviously you were you were you
were sort of because that was your
environment that was the natural leap
but my parents never they didn't really
do that with us I mean it was never I
mean there was always paper and crayons
and pencils and things in my parents
studio and of course yes you you imitate
to a certain degree that what you see in
your environment but my parents never
pushed foisted it never would so ever
your dad your mom was a fashion
illustrator yeah and your dad was a very
successful landscape painter doesn't
work is like he's been everywhere like
the met glioma
you know revered
full artist and you express some
interest in this as a young person right
and he started to teach you at age 12
like this was going to be the path for
you yeah and and I I think you know full
disclosure that was initially the idea
of that was sort of seeking my father's
approval
mmm you know trying to find a common
ground in which I could I could relate
to him because he was a very intense guy
I mean he had an enormous capacity to
love but he was a he was an intense
intense man somewhat of a rageaholic and
not the most patient guy I mean those
are there are certain traits of his that
have crept into my DNA and and you know
there there were times when they eke out
and I'm mortified by them because there
were things that really were a source of
tremendous difficulty for me as a kid
that being said I I kind of fully
immersed myself in that world with my
dad and he was you know he was hard but
I mean it was also good that he was hard
you know my parents were never once to
to just shower praise on my siblings and
myself just to do it you weren't a very
special snowflake no I in that way you
know I mean it didn't work out I mean I
would do a drawing and I would my mother
was it was was much more sort of
sensitive and diplomatic about it
whereas my father would kind of correct
it and you know and and be very critical
of it but I also I signed up for that
yeah so by the time I was around 15 16
III kind of gone through this sort of
formal training with my father as far as
learning how to paint and mix color and
have an understanding of that and
drawing and then so then I'm in high
school
and I'm in art class and I was bored out
of my mind I was I was just bored
because part it was that I already
really there wasn't anything they could
teach me and I had the same experience
when I went to art school they they
couldn't teach me anything I'd already
been taught all of the the technical
things that were important and and I had
a good grasp and understanding of that
what I really needed to do was to paint
on my own and kind of find my own us my
own voice right so after a kind of you
know unproductive year at at art school
at Bennington College in which I you
know more just kind of partied my head
off uh-huh and I have great memories of
that year it was not the most productive
and so when I came out of that and my
father was pissed and understandably you
were just there one year I was just
there a year that uh Bret Easton Ellis
went up Bennington yeah you guys there
at this he was there he was there after
I right there and and so I I knew I was
in trying to my father was gonna be
angry I mean they basically said to me
why don't you take a leave of absence
and then decide if you want to because
basically you know what we're what we're
looking at academically for you is you
just haven't shown up I mean there's you
know you've you've shown up to your
painting classes and you've done some
good paintings and you have you have
talent but you're not you know I just
didn't have any didn't have the passion
for it I didn't have the discipline
really I didn't have the self-discipline
and so my my remedy for that was that I
thought well this really comes down to
it to a self discipline thing I'm gonna
join the Marine Corps and I thought that
would kind of straighten me out uh-huh
and my father said well you before you
joined the Marine Corps your you got to
come home he was very upset and he kind
of put me into this what we my brothers
and I called the inward Bound program
aka and I don't know if I can swear it
somewhere but we he referred to at his
camp [ __ ] up and and
all my brothers and I attended Kaka and
what he within that time while I was
sort of installed and in a little Cape
guest house on my father's land up in
Maine
I lived kind of like Thoreau my you know
was no girlfriends no hanging out boxes
and boxes of books uh-huh and which my
agenda was some kind of academic
curriculum that was the daily you know I
live and and then there was a there was
a plot of land that needed to be that
needed to be cleared so that we could
harvest it for firewood mm-hmm he had a
huge huge just a whack of land several
thousand acres and and it was placed in
a forever wild Conservancy so it could
never be subdivided or built upon and
there was just his compound and then
another little compound and and so I you
know there I was 18 years old living by
myself in this in this cool funky house
with no electric no electricity no
running water or you know an outhouse
and going out in the morning getting up
early and cutting firewood by myself and
doing that and then keeping a daily
journal reading these books and then he
said you can either do you know an oral
presentation about the book or you can
write a paper and because I was lazy eye
doesn't huh I know I didn't want to
subject myself to writing a paper
knowing that he would just be there with
two fists full of red pens and oh man
this is intense it was really intense
and it was sort of you know the the book
showed up and it started you know in
Mesopotamia and then it was like you
know working through you know the
complete works of Faulkner and it was
kind of all over the place and and and
Proust and and it just was endless and I
would I would come into his studio he
could carry on conversations well he
would paint but that was like the inner
sanctum so either if you got called into
my father's studio typically it meant
you were in trouble which were referred
to as studio talks which we dreaded oh
my
and usually it would be his head would
come in a door he'd be in your room I'd
be with my siblings or something and the
door would open my father would say come
in studio time we'd all kind of go like
man this is not gonna end well well so I
did that and it was painful at times you
know I can remember reading a book that
was a tome and then sitting with my
father in a studio for four hours
he's grilling you having the
conversation and finishing it and and he
said yeah you gonna read that again and
to which and you know and I want to say
it wasn't Warren peace but it was
definitely dense right it was definitely
you know Russian literature
you know and and and I said why don't
have to read again he said cuz he didn't
get it and you know and there was no way
my dad was one of those guys where if he
said you're grounded for a month you
were grounded for a month
there was no wiggle room you didn't go
to him after two weeks and say hey you
know I've been I've been toeing the line
I'm doing the thing so you know can I
get off on good behavior I mean he would
hold it right right to the line and he
did that with me and then when he felt
that I had kind of completed that task
which he I proceeded as meet owing him
something because he had he had sent me
to school there hmm and it was really
more about me owing myself and I came
out of that much stronger how long that
go on for Oh months it was all but like
almost a year and and not but he said to
me what do you what are you gonna do now
and I said uh we had many conversations
and one of them we talked about painting
and he said to me when you're not
thinking about girls and beer and and
smoking grass dude what do you think
about do you think about painting and I
said no I don't think about
I think about films and I think about
acting and he said well that's what you
should do because if it doesn't get you
up in the morning and it's and if it's
not on your mind you need to do what's
on your mind and and that and that was
really the first time I'd ever said that
out loud and I'd never told I didn't in
in high school and things but it was for
me it was it was kind of fun right but
that's when I really and he said well
then you better you know you you should
go to New York I want to go to camp in
word bound I don't know we might all be
a little bit better off I we all did a
little camp inward bound you know at the
time I resented it and and and it felt
like a punishment many many times but
the truth the matter is of all the
things that my father gave me over over
you know while he was alive that was the
greatest gift he's a beautiful gift and
and I didn't I wasn't able to see it
until I was away from it and I was a
little bit older that I went oh oh and
just the extraction from society to
isolate you it's just you and him in
books and nature it is very thorough you
know I'm sure you had to it allowed you
to develop that intuition to even answer
that question you know like what do you
think about well it did it also what it
did was it made me rely I it forced me
to be comfortable with myself and to
entertain myself and so I spent you know
when you have that kind of solitude then
when you're kind of brought back into
society there's there's less importance
and in certain social aspects I mean I'm
very comfortable I mean I I'm a social
person I like I like being with people
and meeting people but I'm also fine by
by myself I can I like going for a long
long you know I have a place in upstate
Connecticut and I like just walking
around with my family first and for me
but I'm good being by my something I
don't have a I don't know and I and I
realize that prior to that I really
wasn't comfortable being left with my
own thoughts and it kind of forced me in
that way it forced me to grow up
certainly emotionally definitely
intellectually it kind of pulled pulled
me out of a out of a level of kind of
intellectual and emotional immaturity I
sort of I grew up in that in that time I
kind of grew up now that you know I've
certainly regressed on many an occasion
but I will say that that was that was in
all the years that I was in school I
learned more in that time that I can't
yeah I would imagine so so you end up in
New York after that yeah and none got a
very amorous life you know working
multiple jobs a lot of shitty jobs and
and you know sleeping on people's
couches and not because I couldn't
afford an apartment but it prepared me
for that so I had I had a real survival
instinct you know I never sat down and
thought oh this is terrible so it's so
hard you know at 18 I was living on the
Upper West Side and a funky little
apartment and with my girlfriend and you
know I wasn't you know we we eat by
every month but it was okay yeah I was
okay and I studied at the HB studio in
the beginning the Herbert Berghof studio
because first of all was Austin
Pendleton yeah it was the only place I
could afford I never had Austin as a
teacher I had bill Hickey crazy bill
Hickey as a teacher and Walt with cover
and and a new to Hagen had some great
teachers there yeah I didn't get to know
Austin until many many years later he he
produced a play that Laurence Fishburne
and I did together that Lawrence had
written we did in in New York but you
know it was it was the real deal I mean
it was
it was intense and then I sort of felt
like I was missing something and I
wanted to decide it made the decision to
go back to school that I wanted to go
back and continue my education uh-huh
and so I applied to several schools and
and then when I was accepted into
schools I hadn't needed to make a
decision and I chose to go to NYU and
and I mean that was the best possible
choice I could have made because that's
where I connected with with Mamet and
and lots of great actors and and saw it
through you know and but it was
important to me I felt like that which
it had been inspired by my time with
with with my father but I wanted to
pursue that and isn't one to you you
know you were doing it for yourself not
to impress your father no and that was
the thing that was very liberating was
yeah that that to arrive at that place
and to have that clarity you know the
realization that I was doing it for
myself because it's what I wanted to do
rather than seeking the approval of my
parents that was very liberating mm-hm
and you know it didn't I mean until
practically up until the time my father
died you know he was it was always the
subject of you know dinner conversation
at some point the the bennington story
had to had to come out my father just on
some perverse level really enjoyed
tormenting me about yeah just twisting
the knife with that yeah why were your
siblings in inward bound different
versus similar story
yes similar things just you know you
know he was a stern taskmaster and I
think what happened with a lot of us was
that once we got out into the world and
we felt you know those those tentacles
weren't wrapped around our ankles we
kind of went wild right but you had this
base skills
you know I think you know there's this
idea that the artists life is one of you
know living with your head in the clouds
and here you have your father who's this
incredibly prolific successful painter
but a total taskmaster yeah you know a
very disciplined man from what I gather
yeah who valued hard work yeah and you
know didn't take [ __ ] and didn't suffer
fools and you know when I see the
longevity of your career and how many
people you've worked with I can't help
but think that you bring that level of
discipline and that kind of work ethic
you know how you approach these roles
well I learned that and I think that was
the thing my father came from a you know
a staggeringly poor background and he
grew up in rural northern Pennsylvania
and did not know his father so he was
raised by his grandfather who was a
cabinet maker and and a very gifted guy
but you know it was a little town I mean
people didn't people didn't go become
painters there mm-hmm and so you know
from the time he was a little kid he had
incredible responsibilities which of
course you know it always falls into
that category of you know walking to
school and three feet of snow 12 miles
uphill and things like that but the
stories were true you know and and and
to a certain degree the I think they
they weren't necessarily cautionary
tales but we really had gratitude always
had gratitude as kids my father made a
big point of he was a guy who would give
his last dime to someone who needed it
that's just the way he was I can I can
remember him paying off a neighbor's
mortgage on their farm and and it turned
out that the bank that that held the
mortgage was also the bank where my
father banked and after he got a call
the guy worked for us he was like a
hired hand and he worked at my dad's
place in Maine I didn't come to work my
father called his house cuz the guy was
never a minute late and talked to his
wife and she said well the bank
the bank guys are here and there they're
gonna foreclose on on the house and my
father got in the car and went went down
there and and he pulled out his
checkbook and wrote a check for I think
to the tune of at that time was fifteen
twenty thousand dollars and he wrote the
check and he handed it to the guy and he
said he owns his house now go [ __ ]
yourself oh and by the way after I leave
here I'm I'm coming to the bank I'm
closing all my accounts Wow and he had
been banking there for ever and and you
know he had a very successful career he
you know it was very very successful so
that was a that was a lot of money that
was sitting in their bank but for him
that was a line that you know it was
they were unethical the idea that they
would bully a farmer who could barely
you know scrape it together so this
incredibly principled man you know that
raised you I mean how does this inform
how you raise your kids mean your dad to
three kids we live in a very different
culture than that you know obviously
there's so much value in so many of
those things that he taught you but it's
a little it would be a little bit out of
the norm to be that kind of taskmaster
yeah I'm this day and age I mean you
know how do you how do you take the best
of that and you know channel it
downstream your kids
well my you know Mike my kids have a
very privileged life but they also you
know they've they've been around the
world enough to to see people who have
nothing anime I think that what I have
what I have done what I what I have
strived to do with my kids is to teach
them gratitude and to and kindness and
that and I see that in them they have
great empathy
they're kind they're they're not angels
I can tell you that they are disciplined
to a certain degree but they're also you
know 13 17 and almost 20 so they're
they're very normal in that way I know
they're all on your TV show they're all
yeah yeah
Eamonn pleasure son that's your younger
one Quintin place you're young you're
you're younger young he plays the
younger Harry Bosch okay and then my
daughter did a little a little cameo but
just to to speak to nepotism that they
came to me when they wanted to cast
someone who's gonna play in some of
these flashbacks they had they had met
my kids Eamon was slightly older at the
time
and they asked they said you know does
your does your son Quinn you know he
looks so much like you would you know we
want to maybe we could use him for these
flashbacks and I said I don't know and
so I approached him about it and at
first he was nervous and sitting here I
don't know dad I've only you know you
know I was the teddy bear in the
Christmas play etc etc and and he ended
up doing it and and and he's really good
on the show but that just you know full
disclosure I didn't go to them when they
were Cassie and saying hey how about
hiring my kid and then Michael Connelly
had written the scene on the beach where
this little girl comes and asked my
daughter if she'll push her in this wing
because the father is completely glued
to his cell phone and and Michael had
written that scene he said you know be
great to court could do this which he
want to do so there's that now that
being said what's kind of great with
having all three of my kids being actors
that certainly with my sons for as long
as we do this show we can move them
around in different points of Harry's
life because they're both they're both
really
good actors and I certainly never you
know the same thing as my father I never
pushed them into that I never said so do
you want to be an actor when you grow up
and they're both they're both musicians
they they play a lot of music so who
knows what they'll ultimately end up
doing my and my daughter she's she's 13
I mean yeah you never see wants to be at
she's really interested in in in being
an actor but she's also very interested
in her iPhone too so that becomes the
you know thankfully we didn't we didn't
have it distractions like that I mean my
father felt that we didn't even watch a
lot of TV I watched television of my
mother's house because my father was
kind of anti TV hmm you know it's the
six o'clock news we didn't even have a
color TV I don't think until I was in
high school yeah there there is an
important relationship between boredom
and creativity yeah that we're losing
our connection with that that scares me
you know I have you know an 11 and a 15
year old daughter yeah and yeah they
love their iPhone you know and I it's
problematic yeah it is particularly when
you try to say hey given giving that a
break you see the the it's like trying
to pull a beer out of an alcoholics hand
yeah well and there's more and more you
know data that's showing up now that
that the the the relationship to these
phones because they're not phones
they're they're basically personal
computers their laptop their slot
machine your hands yeah there's slot
machines and so you know it's that
they're it's addiction mm-hmm you know I
find myself what I I've got this thing
on my phone now that tells me how much
time spending on the phone yeah it's
alarming it is alarming even when I feel
like I'm consciously being careful to
try not to use it and there there is a
certain amount of some of it which is a
necessary evil to a certain degree as we
are in a business of having to
the things that we do and social media
is a very good way to do that and to
reach people so you can and you can tell
yourself that that lie like oh well I
need to do this for my work right but in
truth you know it is an addictive
relationship and and you know creativity
spawns out of Solitude yeah right and so
you know how do we you know cultivate
that and our children's lives in our in
our own lives like it requires a lot of
discipline you know that discipline you
know and really being good with
boundaries well we don't have the weed
and grow up with the same yeah I was
informed by it we had we had radio we
had high fives as at home we had record
players and and we had television and
movies were movies there were no I
didn't you know the VCR came along well
after we didn't have that yeah and there
are so many things to distract and now
it's all you know compressed into this
one little thing that we carry around as
being a form of communication it kind of
bums me out I hate to sound like you
know when I would bring my kids that's a
little too much you know we're gonna cut
it down to this amount and I remember my
older son saying I mean that we're not
Amish and I said you know we're not
Amish but I said the amount of time that
you know you spend playing video games
is it's not good it's not good for you
yeah and as somebody who's trying to you
know find their voice you gotta you
gotta find space first well you have to
find you also have to you have to be
able to what it goes back to what I said
you know you have to be comfortable
being by yourself you know to say never
have to be alone anymore
if you know when we as kids if we said
we were bored it was the worst thing you
could possibly say around my father
because he would then find a million
things for you to do that you didn't
want to do and there was some you know I
can ruin I'm saying I was bored and
my father's remedy for that was go
upstairs and and get the a encyclopedia
I went upstairs get the a encyclopedia
bring it down okay what do I do
I read it ha ha ha what do you mean read
it yeah start and so what was
interesting was I was furious and sat
there and he he never let anything go so
it was ours and I'm saying that if he
told you to do it you were gonna do you
did it because we were we had a very
healthy fear of my father and and then
and then it started to become this thing
and reading the encyclopedia and what
was interesting was at a certain point
it started to get good to me uh-huh and
I suddenly realized that these books
that that were you know like the
monolith from 2001 they were always so
intimidating to me were actually great
and I could skip over what I you know I
didn't I didn't have to read everything
but what it did was it it in it was a
level of solitude because it wasn't and
my father would say don't go and sit in
the in the middle of the living room
with that book you go to your room and
you close the door and it was you know I
suppose that's why sometimes there are
nights when I can I can run the board on
Jeopardy and and and I always say
tribute that I'll turn to to my kids and
go I don't I don't know how yeah no I
know how I did you get all the way to Z
no no I got I'm trying to remember the
last I got somewhere around em uh-huh
and then I was out of the house yeah I
mean you can't even find encyclopedias
anymore I still have them I still have
my Encyclopedia Britannica's yeah and we
had another one that was the dealt
purely with science which was great the
encyclopedias of science
I think but also I love to read you know
my thing when I was a kid with my my
iPhone when I was a kid were toys and
comic books and that was my my father
would say I don't want to you know why
don't you read a book you're always
reading that Fantastic Four and no no no
no no no read a book and I love to read
I you know I I knew how to sort of
divide my time that's been the one thing
with my kids that I have felt that I've
I've really had to kind of push a little
bit harder on and that's reading yeah
because there's it's tough it's tough to
get young people to read and then once
they start to do it you know hopefully
they get hooked I mean my my kids read
not as much as I wish that they would
but the flip side of that is that all of
my kids love films and they and they
love to to sit and and and you know I
can sit with them and watch three three
or four films if it's a rainy day it's a
perfect opportunity to just sit and I'll
say oh well we're gonna watch Godfather
one and Godfather two and you get to
work with them it's pretty cool which is
really you know that's the that's the
that's one of the many things but and
also music I mean there's there's still
within the household with with all the
distractions of iPhones and iPads of
which I suffer this you know the same
malady there's there's music playing all
the time my kids love music and and they
like to look at art they have you know
they're that's the thing I mean somebody
said oh you know watch your kids we'll
all end up being lawyers or doctors and
I say well look you know same thing my
father said to me I don't care what you
do as long as it gets you up in the
morning and as long as it fulfills you
and but alas I look at all three of my
kids
III would be surprised if they come to
me and say I'm gonna go to medical
school
I'm gonna go to law school they're
artists and I think that's that's kind
of either it's in your DNA or it's not
in your DNA so where's the the first
like break you're living in New York
that was a lot of theater years and
years of theater doing theater for no
money having no age and agents were very
very hard to get when I was coming up
and ironically I got sort of discovered
in a bar an agent who had seen me in a
play I was actually a Mamet play
American Buffalo that I went on
off-broadway and I was I was in the
saloon that I worked at it was my night
off and I was shooting pool and this guy
came over and said you're tired of
Oliver and I thought Jesus you know I
mean maybe yeah well that's you know
that was always a consideration and and
he said he had seen me in this play and
he asked me who my agent was and I said
I don't have an agent and I you know as
you sort of navigate that you know that
whole weird world you know you
occasionally you know you connect with
somebody and they seem legitimate and
then there's all other there's a weird
angle so I was very I didn't jump right
in and I didn't call him back
I mean initially he gave me his card and
he said give me a call I wanted I want
to talk to you about representing it I
didn't call him I just thought it was
another BS thing and and then he tracked
me down back through mutual friends and
the bar cause he he drank at the at the
bar and and so you know he said you know
what's going on are you you know you you
want representing representation or not
and and I ended up going and taking a
meeting with him and he immediately had
set me up with meetings and the third
audition that he sent me on I got I got
the part and it was a sort of a small
walk-on
scene in a movie called Navy SEALs where
I played this obnoxious redneck and who
goes after Charlie Sheen and Charlie
Sheen's this Navy SEAL and he kind of
beats me up and and then I did the doors
with Oliver Stone right and that was
kind of a that was a long long shoot so
they would they're you know over months
and months they'd fly me out for two
days and they'd say yeah we're not gonna
use you so they'd fly me back to New
York and this kept going on and then I
got cast in a film called The Lofts
Capone which was a was a Turner a TNT
sort of movie of the week miniseries
thing about Al Capone and his brothers
and Eric Roberts played Al Capone and
Adrian Pasdar played the lost Capone who
was Jimmy Capone who kind of fled
Brooklyn after he thought he was
responsible for a a opposing gang
members death and he went on to be the
become this marshal and change his name
to James Hart to gun Hart and during
Prohibition he was knocking over Al's
illegal shipment Sabu's at least that
was the sort of the version that we told
I mean it was a little bit glorified
because apparently he he wasn't the most
honest guy but that that and that was
the thing that I put on a bunch of
weight for right and like 60 pounds yeah
yeah got you know and then was pissed
because I wasn't getting called in for
the leading man roles and it took me a
year to lose that and you know it's kind
of a my career in that way has been kind
of a slow burn you know and I think it
better better than too much too quick
certainly because I while I was
disciplined in my work you know I was
very much out and about all the time big
partier and I don't know that I would
have been able to handle success as he
watched a sim I think it would have I
would have probably crashed and burned
but you've like it doesn't look like you
had any dry spells like you've basically
been consistently consistently working
for sure but there were definitely
periods where you know where there were
dry spells and also me trying to step
away from stuff you know I would get
because one of the one of the you know
the it's such a cliche but you do you
can if you do something well sometimes
you get the engine hold I mean how did
you become you know the kind of hard-ass
cop do you have like a sweet guy you
know I don't I don't you know in
spending time with you personally it's
not like you come off naturally that way
no maybe you do were when you were
partying oh no I I mean yeah definitely
when I was when I was when I was deep in
the tank
I was certainly you know there's a long
and and somewhat undistinguished list of
people that I've you know had physical
altercations with in in in my younger
years and to a certain degree had had a
bit of a chip on my shoulder so I was
very for me it was easier to gravitate
towards confrontation than not and some
of that has to do with the way that I
was raised the kind of guy my father was
he was a very confrontational guy so I
grew up in an environment where that was
there all the time
and kind of underlying and but I spent a
lot of time I tend to sort of NAB those
roles the cop roles because I spent a
lot of time around cops I was around
cops had a lot of cop friends so I'd go
in to read for these characters and it
would resonate the people kind of go oh
that's kind of great this I mean I
remember a couple times people saying
are you were you a police officer before
no no no I'm you know Oh what happened
to your accent I thought you were from
Brooklyn no I don't have an accent I you
know
but so I don't know I don't know I don't
you know I certainly now that being said
I was doing those roles in it and that
was fine but I started to get a little
bit bored
mm-hmm because there's only so many ways
you can reinvent the wheel particularly
if it's not on the page and it well it
came all in time it was the second I
want to say the second season of NYPD
Blue
the word all changed where I got a call
oh they want you to come in and read for
this role of playing this this trauma
surgeon this doctor and I thought
because I had been so conditioned to
what Hollywood's perception of who I was
and what I what I should be playing I
remember saying I'm manager I don't want
to waste a meeting with David Milch and
Steven Bochco
for a role that they're not gonna cast
me in and I said well that's the one
that's the one so I went in and I kind
of pulled myself together I put on my
reading glasses and button myself down
and comb my hair and and and and end up
getting I was sort of cast right on the
spot Milch milf said to me you want to
play this role and you know it's you and
that that came in a moment and it
completely changed the perception of of
a what I could do and suddenly I was
playing well I said I went from being
mono syllabic to polysyllabic and with
with one with one character and and and
that was this role of dr. Mons a con
NYPD Blue and I they would bring me back
here and then I pulled me back in for
something you know Sipowicz was Dean had
a friend who had dementia or he was
having you know which tenet did you do
run out this was was the American
Buffalo that you did with Denis France
no no no that was a that was a camera
with the directors name that was with
Dustin Hoffman and I came over the kids
name who that was the film the guy was
from Providence were Alan anyway so then
all of a sudden I'm not
being you know called in to be the cop
or to be the Knockaround guy and I was
playing lawyers I was playing playing
dads but there was always sort of a poll
also and by the same at the same time to
play tough guys right villains which I
don't I there they're actually they're
fun characters to play I would say it's
it's more fun to where the guy with the
black is it play the guy with the black
hat than the white hat for one thing you
know the sort of sky's a limit you know
you're playing villains these are people
who don't play by the rules and so
there's something kind of insanely heady
about playing people who don't play by
the rules they just kind of it you know
and I and I knew guys who were who were
in organized crime
I observed those guys so I knew who they
were you know and to watch them come
into into an establishment where people
knew who they were and the kind of
deference and also still the kind of
yeah fear that they instilled in people
despite the fact that they were being
incredibly charming when they would walk
in shaking everybody's hands and hey how
you doing no no no no no no no you knew
that 90% of the people that were
interacting with them were they felt
that it was out of survival they were
scared they didn't they weren't looking
at these people and saying oh you know
hey killed a couple people but really at
the end of the day is just a nice guy
yeah so those and also I don't like to
stigmatize characters as being you know
if you're playing a villain you know you
can't have judgment honor you can't have
judgment on don't play the result don't
come in you know unless of course you're
doing a Disney character or something
like that where it's required to
Telegraph that and well that's a more
one-dimensional you know portrayal yeah
and it's not as interesting a bad guy
yeah it's just not as interesting so
those
and some of those villains were they
were really fun to play I mean Jimmy O
on Sons of Anarchy just you know that
was a really that was a bad dude he was
a really bad guy he was a really and and
yet my thought about him was just a guy
who he was just a businessman who had
initially kind of started out as a guy
on the righteous side of being in in in
the IRA in the Irish Republican Army you
know under the tyranny of the British
government that he was that the guy had
a you know as a soldier he was doing but
then he got into selling guns and then
he kind of got corrupted and sort of
lost his way and became just another
common criminal how is it working with
Curt great it was great Sutter and I had
a lot of fun we remain friends to this
day and he's been always been very
supportive of other work that I've gone
on to do I really enjoyed working with
him a lot
he's an you know an extraordinarily
bright guy and and very funny I mean I
always cracks me up the way he he refers
to himself as Walter Mitty with anger
issues I mean oh yeah he's a
I mean he's another guy who when you
spend time with him you're like he's
kind of a sweet teddy bear but he has
this persona this larger-than-life bad
guy persona and he's intimidating he's a
big dude yeah he's got some anger stuff
yeah for sure but but he's sweet yeah
the the the at his core you know he's
very very sweet guy mm-hmm and you know
people you see him with his kids yeah he
sees well I think with all of us right
that's that becomes the thing I mean you
know that which we how we are in the
world and then you know it's our
children our our lives all Tianna in
that way right people always say oh when
you're what is it how do you define
being a parent and I say you define
being a parent is when when you become a
parent you have one of two things either
you you go oh I'm a parent or you have
the realization it's this incredible
Epiphany
of what a what true love is
and also selflessness hmm it's at that
where you say I would I would make the
element the ultimate sacrifice this is
where I would do that yeah and I think
Kurt is one of those people I mean I
think he uses his art his writing his
creative expression as a way to exorcise
the demons house within absolutely you
know present and loving you know partner
and and and father yeah
so we're how does how does a Ben Affleck
come into the picture because you become
like his dude you're in all his movies I
mean they're all like crazy awesome he's
a great listener I mean the mustache
that you were rocking in Gone Baby Gone
is like will go down in cinema history
what are the all-time great mustaches in
movies except for sample yet he's still
that's - yeah well nobody can grow a
mustache like that saying but but that
you know the handlebars down the side
that was something to behold that was a
the chops I had just finished shooting
Deadwood or we were finishing it up and
I and I read the script Gone Baby Gone
thought it was great went in to be put
on tape for him to see and it was also
the first time that I had seen something
since the Friends of Eddie Coyle which
was a film that I love so much that
takes place in Boston really deals with
those kind of underworld characters and
so I went in and I got put on tape and
then I didn't hear anything for ever and
ever and ever and and then months later
my my then manager says hey you got a
callback for Ben Affleck and I said for
what for Gone Baby Gone I said talk
Jesus is that still going on
he said yeah so I go in I kind of
prepare myself again and go in and and
read for Ben and it's sort of like the
typical come in hi hi okay let's just
you have any questions no I'm just gonna
jump in and do the couple of scenes and
then Ben starts you know he starts the
conversation after the audition
and uh like a half a minute in he goes
what happened to your accent what accent
no so are you from Boston I said no I'm
not from Boston where do and I said no
my mom lived in Boston I went to
boarding school
in Maine and I have a lot of you know
I've had a lot of you know connective
tissue in with New England and
everything so I know that I I know the
accent and I when I when I got there
before the meeting I was looking around
and and the waiting room was filled with
all these fosston guys well no they
weren't they were but they were all
really established character actors who
were older because that character was at
least 15 years older than I was when I
played it
on screen so I remember thinking to
myself it's gonna be a stretch now I
when I went in I had hair down to here
and my I was still doing Deadwood so my
beard was twice the size it is now so I
kind of you know had my hair pulled back
and made a little bun to try to pull
that off and but I remember seeing all
these character actors and just thinking
yeah you know it's great that I can even
come in but it's not gonna happen and so
and then I was cast and I think the
first of all Ben's an extraordinarily
bright guy he's a really really
intelligent man yeah I've heard that
from a lot of people and very funny
I mean hysterically funny and and we
just we kind of hit it off not kind of I
mean we really really hit it off and
then when we after I was cast you know
he said look I don't want you to don't
cut your hair and don't shave off the
beard because I don't we got to figure
out what we're gonna do with this
characters look and and so we got the
boss and we sort of ran through the
whole thing and I said look this long
hair and this beard isn't gonna work for
this character but I'd like to you know
have like a handlebar mustache and cut
my
err short but get it cut either I'll cut
it myself for you no because I don't
want to look like a guy who spends a lot
of time on his appearance and so I went
into the to the hair trailer and and my
friend Trish Sweeney who I worked with
her on a couple of things I said let's
just make it look like it's it's a bad
Supercuts job which took more effort to
make it look like a bad Supercuts job
and then and he and he signed off on the
mustache so I you know I took it all off
in the mustache but that hold the whole
process of making that film here was Ben
who was that was the first time he was
directing and he just never had a sense
of that I mean his confidence I mean his
great humility don't get me wrong but he
knew exactly what he was doing hmm he
was so well prepared you know it was a
great cast I mean now you know I was you
know ed Harris and Morgan Freeman just
the name name you know and and then Amy
you know we we played siblings and and
and amy madigan played my wife and it
was just one of those you felt like you
were you were making a small independent
film with a better big-time actors yeah
yeah but it was great I mean just the
energy on the set and Casey and and
Michelle was such a wonderful cast of
actors it holds up so well I mean you
really see somebody who understands
their craft you know the guy who made
that movie I mean for a first-time
director ya know even given that he's
been around for a long time I mean
that's a you know a tall order to fill
well and that's because the scope of
that film was very very big it's not a
small independent movie that is a no
it's not it's a big movie the first time
he showed me his first pass of the film
I can't remember how long it was but I
can I remember I went with my with my
late wife we went to his office and he
said
up with a big screen in one of the
offices and and it's a long film but it
seemed to go by like that and it was
kind of patiently waiting and went what
do you think and and I honestly couldn't
answer him I was still in the film you
know I said don't my right I don't know
what to say and he what do you mean and
I said I have to this I have to digest
that what I've just seen because it was
one of the first times where I watched
something that I had acted in and was
not aware right you weren't like so this
was that was the day that you know we
started late and you know there was none
of that nor was I watching my
performance and going yeah or that take
or I don't like that angle or I just I
was completely drawn into the film and
got lost and in in the film and and then
of course he went on to do the town
which now was it still had that energy
of being a very familial kind of
independent world but really a huge
budget and and that's the way the he
creates an environment a creative
collaborative environment where you you
you will you know that you're involved
with something that's that's special so
you have a sense when when you're in the
midst of shooting of the quality of the
product that it's gonna become because I
you know often I would imagine you might
think it's all going great then you see
it later and you're like that movie your
harmonica unfortunately I've had a lot
of those experiences where the thing
feels like it's it's something and then
you look at the final product and you
you know i-i've just been gobsmacked at
times where I thought how could you take
something that felt so right and and the
end result just be so completely off the
mark and wrong but that's book you know
without without failure certainly I mean
in in all degrees and in life without
failure you can't have any any true
success you don't learn but well it's
it's a miracle any movie gets made you
know and when you see a bad movie nobody
signed up for a bad movie you know you
know everybody went in with the best of
intentions it's just so difficult it is
and when something turns out great I
mean that's just miracle upon miracle
well and also the the whole kind of when
I was coming up the independent film
market was still really really strong
you just see less and less of these sort
of interesting little films although
they kind of they end up getting these
these lives in the streaming thing yeah
I mean we're seeing you know whether
it's Amazon or Netflix or Hulu and all
these other streaming platforms are
filling that void that used to be you
know the Focus Features and the raw
maxes of the world you know it's it's
it's an ebb and a flow on some level it
seems like there's more outlets and
opportunities now to work you know
there's so much content being critic
you know I'm like two seasons behind on
Bosh I can't keep up I know everything
that's coming at me now no it's hard
because there is I mean every time you
turn on the thing there's something new
there's something new which is good and
also you know with with technology being
where it is I mean people are going out
and making films on their iPhones right
and they have this soda purchase made
that that movie high flying bird yeah
all with an iPhone yeah right so you
know back in the day if you had a VHS
you could you could make you know a
funky little thing but it was never
gonna yeah I know I saw I watched our
ago a couple weeks ago that movie holds
up so well it's a good film it's so good
it really I really hope Affleck finds
his way back to that kind of work
oh yeah he's he's always got stuff going
he's always gotten things going you know
and he but he's a you know he's a triple
threat he's a really really great actor
and he obviously you know an Oscar Oscar
winning writer and just I have to say
pound for pound one of the best
directors I've ever
I've just what is the difference between
a great director and a you know a an
everyman director you know what are the
qualities that you look for well I think
first of all he's a very he's the most
prepared director I've ever worked with
and that's not to say that other
directors that I worked with weren't
prepared there's he has an understanding
of it in its totality I mean you can
sort of that the whole film is in his
head when he's working and he's not
flipping open a screen and looking at a
storyboards and a pre-visualization the
whole thing is in his head it's it's cut
in his head and he knows he just knows
every aspect of it you know he's been
he's probably committed the whole script
to memory and there's just something
about his excitement he's still he
hasn't become cynical in all the years
that he's been acting and in this
business and making films he's not
cynical he still has that excitement and
and that's very contagious and he's very
collaborative he's very clean he's very
open and you don't always find that you
know sometimes you just feel like a
guest in somebody's house and and you
know and you you don't want to turn down
the broccoli or something for fear that
you'll offend he's just very he's he's
inclusive in that way within within the
process and you know and he's also a guy
who will who will say we got it is there
anything you want to you want to do a
free one you want to just throw it up in
the air and see what happens he's very
smart and I think that is just you know
what it what it is he's very very he's
very intelligent so he has all the
departments are kind of covered he's
very literally as a very literate mind
he has a really great technical mind so
he understands the camera completely and
editing
and it's just a lot to be said for being
very well-prepared I mean there's
nothing it's it's all been carefully
conceived which doesn't mean that he
won't deviate from from that which he
the ideation knows exactly what he wants
clear vision but it's online did in
collaborative yeah yeah and so you've
been in all of his movies if I if he was
sitting across from me right now and I
was likewise Titus your dude I don't
know I don't know what he would say he
would say something he'd make a smartass
remark yeah he'd probably say so we
didn't answer it directly now hey you
knew you probably not gonna tell me no
no I don't I did you know he would
definitely make fun of me because he's
he's prone to there's a lot of
ball-breaking
also which is we just want to heat the
the sets are I mean some of the it's
just a lot of laughter I mean I I even
in the Serie particularly the more
serious a subject the more laughter
there is which is always kind of it's
nice because it takes the takes the edge
off but I mean I can remember days of
doing scenes on the town where he he
just can't help himself you need do you
do it do us do a scene and you know nail
it and like cut you go okay and go yeah
yeah well we have to move on but yeah it
was pretty good then you can go oh do
you want to do it again
oh it's not it's not getting any better
I mean it's just sort of this thing
where it's just a constant taking the
piss the day goes faster but there's I
don't know there's something about that
it just makes it more fun and I always
feel like you know in actors who work
with him they they get that with Ben you
know they they because he he's not gonna
leave until he sees you okay which is
which is something that you don't always
get you know he'll he will not move on
till ago you okay
you good yeah you sure
to which the first time he ever said
that to me I said boy why why I asked me
if I'm sure because are you sure he came
up as an actor and he cares and he knows
he knows the agony of that thing of
second-guessing that sometimes actors
can can go but you know if somebody said
to me for the rest of your career you're
only gonna work with Ben Affleck I would
be more than happy with that yeah that's
cool is is there a huge difference
between that I mean you've done these
huge movies like transformers I mean
it's gotta be a whole different animal
altogether yeah because that those
things really become less about
performance I mean well you have to you
really use your imagination with those
sounds so in that way they're really fun
but the but doing the Transformers film
was the most physically taxing job I've
ever had to do because you're just
you're you're constantly running running
or shooting or fighting it's like to be
Tom Cruise it's like again well and you
know he's the master of that and you
know it's and it's a very very very
technical those films because we're
you're you know you're reacting to
things that aren't there and and you
know once again Michael Bay very very
well-prepared guy I mean he's he's got
it all in there and yet he'll throw
stuff at a left field sometimes he'll
just the world is his muse he'll come up
and say you know what we're gonna do it
this way seems counterintuitive to what
you're trying to do but he's very smart
and he'll throw it up in the air but I
had fun I had fun doing that film I mean
I I you know Michael is a he's a Yeller
man he he yeah there's all these he gets
mythic stories he gets loud he gets loud
and he but he's also you know he's he's
a taskmaster he wants he wants it to be
great he Michael never wants something
to just be good and I don't think
any director worth their salt or actor
or anyone just wants something to be
good serviceable I mean he wants it to
be great and and then and beyond great
and he puts you know an incredible
amount of energy into that and he
expects everyone to do that and
sometimes people don't meet his
expectations and he's just not always
very good or diplomatic and expressing
his his concerns or his dissatisfaction
but I found him I liked him very very
much and we we worked really well
together and he's also a guy who who
will torment you and break your balls
but then right that kind of that kind of
worked well as a big comic book guide
you like would you want to dip your toe
in the whole Marvel Universe yeah I
would it's just I mean you know I did I
recurred on the show agents of shield I
came out of doing on this Marvel short
which they put on the blu-ray release of
Avengers called item 47 it was like
little short film Easter egg films that
they make and now when you go to see a
Marvel film you know that you got to
hang out because there's at least one if
not two Easter eggs
so you're solidified in the Canon as
that person yeah I mean look is it you
know it was it was a dream when I was a
kid to just know you never thought that
they were ever gonna make us play movie
and they weren't they weren't making
those any when they finally made the the
Superman movie with Christopher Reeve it
was you know I remember thinking great
now the doors are gonna open and you
know Marvel will start doing this and
you wait until your fifties yeah but I
enjoy those films I mean I thoroughly
enjoy you know they're they're really
well crafted and I feel like the whole
the whole Marvel Universe those
characters is very sophisticated Stan
Lee had a kind of genius you know
himself and all the people that he
surrounded himself with and collaborated
you know it's I look forward to then
people complain they go I don't want to
see another superhero movie and I get it
to a certain degree but I'm ok with it
because you know it's it's such an
interesting thing like if you didn't
know that about you like you just don't
stray
me as you know coming from this artists
background and you know serious painter
father and all of that you know NYU
David mammoth theater you're you don't I
wouldn't I wouldn't presume that you
would be like this comic-book guy but I
know like how like he'll you much of a
fan you know all my yeah because cuz her
side you're a week for sideshow yeah I'm
a total nerd I'm a nerd I mean and and I
was exactly the kid turns into a kid
when he cut yeah I know I can't get rid
of this guy wants to come sideshow every
day I know they gotta give me a key card
although you know but that that that's
my I don't know that I I've always been
immersed in sort of pop culture but of
course I you know growing up in the 60s
that's when that pop culture kind of
exploded everything became bigger and
more colorful with the psychedelic art
and you had Peter Max and Roy
Lichtenstein and and Marvel Comics kind
of blew up and toys were kind of in you
had Hot Wheels cars and GI Joes and Easy
Bake Ovens and all this stuff and you
know there's a part of it that that we
just don't have any you know it's like
now we have we have phones yeah you know
my when I was a kid I had all that so I
had comics and stuff but I have the
little plastic soldiers and big chunks
of modeling clay and you just lose
yourself for hours doing that stuff and
and I just think it was just part of my
life and it just never left to me it's
sort of like comfort food to a certain
to a certain degree and I like and I you
know when I saw sideshow I mean this and
that was a when sideshow came around it
was a game changer you know and they and
initially and I was hip to them from
when they came out publicly and they're
they're they're first stuff was you know
the the World War one things and and the
the you know the General Custer and the
Billy the Kid and all these kind of
interesting
it-it-it took that whole thing to a
different level I mean it's Greg and I
have had those conversations where I've
said to them you know all these people
who work not only at sideshow in the
different ways that they work there
whether they're sculptors or the boxart
people or the photographers or the mold
makers the painters these people are are
they're all artists yeah incredible
artists incredible artists people if
they wanted to be just working within
the fine art world but then I say but
then how can you really differentiate
what because it's you know it's still
art to me as it's pop culture yeah but
so people sort of tend to sort of poopoo
it and we should say for people that are
listening I don't know sideshow is a is
a company that's run by our mutual
friend collaborative partner in my case
Greg Anzalone and they make very
high-end limited edition runs of
collectable figures from pop culture so
the Star Wars movies marvel over CC and
then their own stuff and they do
sculptures they do 1/6 scale you know
12-inch figures and there are 33 points
of articulate yeah
and it's staffed by these artists as you
mentioned who are incredibly skilled at
you know painting in the greatest detail
or crafting you know costumes and
sculptors people that if there was no
sideshow yet when it will wear with
these people be able to do what they do
like they they have this home where they
can go and do what they love and do it
incredibly well in a supportive
environment to create these things that
people love I mean you know I didn't
grow up with comic books and this is you
know a new experience for me like
tapping into this subculture but you got
a comic-con and they have this
second-biggest booth on the floor yeah
people are freaking out and there's
collectors all over the world I mean
caramel del Toro like as a whole oh yeah
room in his house filled with this stuff
no his house is a museum
collected a bunch of it as well oh no I
have a
and there's a whole world it's easy for
it to take over but I have a room which
is sort of like we'll call it the the
screening room for because I just man
cave just it's just a word that really
bugs me man cave that's like I don't
know it's like the little rascals what
was at the the he-man girl haters club
that the the alfalfa had you know tacked
on on the tree house the toxic
masculinity oh I don't even need yeah I
guess so
maybe it's the toxic masculinity but but
I have this room where my my screen TV
is in and where I go and watch movies
and things like that and it's just a
series of shelves that are just you know
filled with sideshow stuff yeah and and
it and and that's my that's my sort of
you know my fortress of solitude I can
go in there and close the doors and it's
not like I'm I'm getting up and posing
these things all over the place but a
lot of them because they relate directly
to two films that I love there's
something there's this odd connection
between looking at you know Ironman on
in the movie and then looking over in
the shelf and there is there it is and
you can you know there's that tactile
experience of lifting up the visor and
there's Robert Downey jr. 'he's face and
the fingers are articulated and all that
stuff I mean you know it's it's it's
hard at times to sort of articulate that
to people who don't have any connection
to it they'll kind of but eventually
people sort of come around to see us no
they think aesthetically but then the
the the other irony of that is that
people will come to my house and you
know for a dinner party or something and
everybody ends up down in the well at
some point because it seems like a
museum both men and women will come in
and go wow this is this is incredible
what are all these things or or they'll
say oh I remember that's from
this movie or that movie would be and
they get it I mean they do get it
whether it's something they want to do
themselves as it's a totally different
thing but they get it there's a I don't
know there's some sort of a connection
and I always say you know it's not it's
not hurting anybody
yeah yeah what's the the project that's
still out there that your spirits
yearning to do is there a movie you've
always wanted to make or a character
you've always wanted to play well I've
started to I I wrote a television pilot
for myself several to television pilots
for myself a couple years ago when I was
kind of disenfranchised with the whole
business and and I thought you know I I
gotta create something that I can really
connect to and you know interestingly
enough just as I was getting ready to go
out to the to the pitch phase with my
manager to start to do that is when Bosh
landed on my on my desk but I've I
started writing a screenplay with my
oldest son Eamon last summer and I've
got a lot of stories I have a lot of
stories and the TV pilots I don't I you
know they're good I'd like to but I
maybe for one I think I might be a tad
old for it now mm-hmm which is okay and
I'm you know I'm hoping that will that
Bosh will run for for many many years
because it's such a character it's a
character that I'd love playing you know
and he's you know even in his 60s in the
books and the whole chronology the books
he's in his sixties is he still working
it's like a volunteer yeah cold-case
detective left on this thing you know
he's he's not going anywhere so I I
guess what I'd like to ultimately do is
to start to direct and or act in films
that I write and do them with my friends
and do them with my family because I
think there's those have always been
kind of dreams of mine then that they
don't need to be gigantic films but
that's always been and I've experienced
that working with Ben and with
laurence fishburne when you work with a
and now so with with bosch when you work
with a with a group of people that are
you know family and friends you get you
get a lot more done and I think you get
the best stuff done when you're working
with a group of people or there is
mutual respect and Trust and you don't
feel necessarily like you're a hired gun
and and I know that it probably sounds
Marxist to a certain degree but it's it
it's worked it's worked for me when I've
had those experiences I've always
thought I'd really like to recreate this
at another point and have a little bit
more control over it mmm do you look
back on your career and wonder how it
all came to be or does it feel like ya
supposed to be here doing what I'm
supposed to be doing yeah I felt that I
mean there have been times when I've
thought particularly in the dry times in
the lean times in the hard times you
know I can remember early on kind of
thinking to myself am i I'm I'm either
either this is a great decision or I'm
the most irresponsible person on the
planet and and and and you know the
pursuit of being an artist in whatever
discipline of art you know by by
society's estimation it is irresponsible
you know so it's just things people say
what are you gonna fall back on you know
right it is kind of an outlaw you know
way to live your life I'm okay with that
axe yeah I'm okay because it's to me I
remember at one point when I I had kind
of a bumpy semester when I was at NYU I
wish I never said you know I had a
girlfriend that was in in another city
and I was you know not going to class
and going to see her and and my my
father was was agitated with me and kind
of brought it up and said hey I just got
your midterm grades you know and you're
kind of you're floundering here and
there and
and it's time for you got to go back to
inward bow well I thought yeah this is
round two right yeah although at that
point I was old enough to say well I'm
you know I'm 21 you can't you can't pull
me back into the graduate school of
inward bound camp [ __ ] up and and he he
said look you know nobody's nobody's
forcing you to do any of this stuff I
mean if you're not you know and I don't
think that you need a college education
in order to to achieve success but you
know if you're not gonna if you're not
gonna see this through then you know
don't waste
don't waste time don't don't waste money
and and I realized that because he said
to me all arts a little long a little
boring and I really resonated with me
because it was it was at a time when I
was kind of going yeah you know I don't
know I don't know is this what it's
because there's so much of that in the
beginning as an out of so much
desperation there's so much pressure and
and you see not only yourself but other
people so focus sometimes on entirely
the wrong things you know they're
talking about you know the social aspect
of well if like if I can you know get
invited to some of these parties I could
go and move and shake or oh I met this
producer and you know at the end I'm
here to tell you that that's [ __ ]
it's empty it you know I've never been
I've been in many many parties with
famous directors and studio heads and
producers that could you know they don't
walk up to you at a party and say you
need to be the star in my next picture
kid yeah it's just I was just having
that conversation with my eldest boy the
other night at dinner it was his
birthdays musician you know he's trying
to make his way and and he's very
grounded guy but I was relating that
same thing there's this sense when you
come to LA or whether it's New York and
you're trying to pursue this career in
the entertainment business that you got
to be at all these parties or if you're
at the right bar whatever you're going
to meet that person it's like the people
that are successful or
into bed early and they're [ __ ]
working yeah you know hard grinding for
a long time and ultimately you know the
cream rises to the top yeah and those
are the people that become employed and
make their way ya know it's it look it's
it's not for everyone it's certainly not
for the faint of heart
you know that that thing I can remember
you know being in a friend's house or
something and they had a very different
environment which they grew up in the
parents would say so
so Titus what are you gonna do if this
doesn't work out and it never occurred
to me that it wasn't gonna work out and
that's not because I was arrogant I just
I knew that this was the only thing that
I really wanted to do yeah for somebody
like you there's value in not having a
plan B oh my you have the constant but I
grew up with parents who'd that was the
same thing my parents never had a plan B
and people thought that my father was
crazy and you know with my mother she
was was very very gifted she got ended
up getting a teaching gig very very
early on but then also kind of realized
that her focus was was being sort of you
know watered down a bit because she had
she had the security of having a fairly
you know a regular daily job which she
could depend on and she said you know I
started to she said I got soft she said
I got soft and I kind of lost my way for
a minute because I was comfortable I
felt safe and that's what my parents did
and she said you know and she said and
then I got a job I got a job being you
know as a fashion illustrator and she
said I stopped teaching and I get that
you know that's so for you the job
becomes how do you not get soft because
you have you know you have predictable
employment playing the same character
for not just the foreseeable future but
perhaps for a very long time
right and it would be very easy for you
to just kind of settle into that you
know show up and check the box as an
artist you know how do you maintain you
know that that tension to keep pushing
the envelope and testing yourself
well hey you do other stuff right which
keeps it fresh but also I mean one of
the considerations that I had when I
thought I wanted to go and do a series
you know as this was approaching my my
late wife was very very ill and McCain
clear that she was going to die and her
and I I realized that what I probably
was going to have to do was to try to
find a television series it's something
that would be grounded stability keep me
home and they would have some stability
but of course there's no guarantees in
those things so I was working on this
thing for myself and it had legs and I
thought okay I can do that but there
there is always there was always a sort
of a hesitation to a certain degree even
when I desperately needed money and to
survive to do the regular jumping
through hoops of pilot season
you know you'd read something and you
you kind of go yeah yeah I'll do that
and well you got to move to Vancouver oh
really
uh well maybe not but you need to make
you know you know and I had three kids I
had to take care of and and a sick wife
and but when so when Bosh came along it
became that thing of sort of I would
start to write before that I was looking
at pilot scripts and in in the process
of working in this business particularly
when you're kind of a hired gun and
you're out and you're kind of working
here and going to do that show and to
that I observed a lot of times people
who had been in shows that had been
either running for a long time or maybe
not only running for a couple of seasons
but I saw an environment which people
were not
be and I think that happens sometimes
people sign up to do something because
it looks good on paper but and I just
knew myself well enough that if I was
going to sign on to do a series it had
to be a character which is one of the
reasons that was the impetus for writing
my own thing is that I would need to
have a character that was going to offer
me some sort of intellectual artistic
sustenance that would carry me through
so that I wouldn't be that guy who would
show up on the set not really happy with
what the Karen the writers are doing
with my character and and being a prick
and kind of punishing everyone for
getting this opportunity or being on a
on a set where the two leads of the show
don't speak to each other or they don't
they they fight with the with the
writers and you know and I just thought
I don't you know it's it's hard enough
to be for that grind of a television
series and you know number one but if
it's if you're knocking heads with
people all the time I horrible and I
looked at that remember Michael Connolly
we were shooting the pilot and Connolly
said to me let me ask a question how did
he write the pilot he was one of the
writers on the pilot with Erik Overmeyer
but they worked very closely together it
Mike said how long how long would do you
think you'd want to play this character
for and the honest answer was I'll play
this guy as long as they'll have me
because Bosch is the kind of character
you're lucky if one character like that
comes along you're your career I've had
lots of characters that I that I've
thoroughly I've been very lucky that way
they've been very very few jobs where
I've kind of gone Jesus this again I
don't really want it but okay because I
got a you know I got a mortgage and car
payments in private school to pay for
it's just the K he the interesting thing
about re Bosch is that he as a as a
person doesn't necessarily evolve his
evolution comes out of circumstances
around him
yeah and so it's it's incremental the
progression of this character but at its
core I liked it I really liked this guy
now
I really liked Jimmy Oh Jimmy o'phelan
as well he was a fun character to play I
mean he was his moral compass was so
magnetized and he he couldn't find his
ass with a map but there was an energy
and and and a kind of a pulse and a
movement of that character that Kurt had
created that made it very fun to play
and so that's the short answer or the
long answer about playing a character on
a series if it's if it's really well
realized you know I think if you get to
a point where they run out of gas
which wouldn't happen with the character
like Bosh but I've seen other shows
either they they come out of the box and
they have tremendous success and it's
explosive and ratchet and then you get
into season four and all sudden you kind
of you can see them losing their way or
what they and then they lose their way a
little bit and there's some criticism
there and then the next season you watch
it and it bears no resemblance to the
show that you fell in love with because
you go oh they're in the hamster wheel
and so they're good there's more
explosions you know and and aliens
aliens and ass and you know what have
you and gunplay and that's that's not to
say that those things don't have value
you know I always say you know they're
people well all art yes all art is
subjective but all art is not
necessarily subjective because there's
there's good art and there's bad art but
the one thing I always rehearse
something that my dad said was bear in
mind though good art and bad art it
takes an equal amount of energy to make
bad art as it does to make good art so
in that regard it is subjective but
I think it I think it just has to do
with as long as there is there has to be
something there that is moving you hmm
because it is easy I would say you know
look and I I'm just been recurring on
Law & Order Special Victims Unit and
Marishka is an old friend of mine and
they're in their 19th season moving into
their 20th season how does she stay
energized you know because the scripts
are good yeah and the character is
interesting and there and and they find
ways to to move that character
periodically out of out of the comfort
zone once she's become an advocate for
women as a result of the position that
that role is placed her in yeah and
that's and she would be the first to say
as long as it's as long as they keep it
interesting you know you don't have to
they don't have to put on a rocket ship
you know or cure world hunger to make
that character interesting yeah but it
is is formulaic as a show is going to be
I mean there's certain beats it's almost
like it's soothing because when you
watch it cuz you just know you kind of
know how it's gonna unfold right it's
comfort food yeah exactly but it's also
no harm no foul right I love you know
stranger things I people either really
respond to that show or they kind of go
I don't get what everybody's know that
show for me is pure crack I love every
aspect of that show I love the
performances the writing the
cinematography the music the the whole
concept of the show to me now does that
tickle that collector pop-culture comic
book nerd itch that I have yeah but I
also think it has above the the the
value of entertainment it has it has
value and to me it's art yeah there's
there's huge artistic merit in that show
absolutely but I can also watch
something like you know fixer-upper
which
is kind of but now and to a certain
degree but I but I'm entertained by it
you know but I'm not but I can't I can't
watch The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills or the Kardashians because that I
I'm physically soul-killing
its soul kill yeah and I'm physically
allergic to that stuff in May it makes
me ill and you know there there are I'm
pretty permissive as a parent what I'll
allow I mean I try to particularly with
my daughter to not expose her to things
or you know themes that might be a
little bit too sophisticated for her age
but the one thing that I'll put my foot
down is that I don't want her watching
that [ __ ] and I've said to her it's bad
for your soul you know and if an adult
wants to make that choice to watch that
you know that's I don't I I just you
know I don't I don't want her watching
that stuff because that's not and not
everything needs to be inspirational you
know it's not that I just I don't know
itta famous yeah it offends me it hurts
it hurts my like you said it's so
pushing I want to be respectful of your
time we've been going a long time and I
want to let you go soon but there's two
more things I want to talk to you about
if you will indulge me the first thing
is you've mentioned gratitude a couple
times yeah so I gather that you know
this practice of gratitude is a central
aspect of how you kind of navigate your
life well I was I was raised that way
because both of my parents grew up my
mother I think was a little bit more
upper upper middle or middle class
mm-hmm my father grew up really poor
really really really poor and there was
a constant reminder
to have gratitude for things that we
have because there were so many people
who didn't have things I remember the
first time my father took us as a family
to the Yucatan and I had never seen
poverty like that before
I mean I certainly growing up in New
York and Philadelphia and stuff you saw
slums but I can remember being in a
going through a little village and being
stunned and my dad was one of the also
one of those guys who would who would
you know grab a copy of National
Geographic you know when he didn't want
to eat cauliflower and you know show you
children with rice belly and exposed
ribs and but that's because he grew up
with I mean they they hunted and trapped
and and you know they were and made
their own food and grew their own food
and so my parents were very we're always
very very big on gratitude and I
realized that it's something that's
that's always kind of served me well
because I think you know it's very easy
with things being so readily available
to us that we take a lot of that stuff
for granted but but gratitude is I just
think it's it's integral to having you
know to everything to make you a a a a
sort of fully well realized human being
I mean I I'm look I'm flawed I mean I
I'm a deeply flawed human being and and
I've had my struggles in many different
areas in in my adult life but I've also
found that that the parallel to that a
lot of times was when I when I got
myself into a dark place her into a
place where trouble was that I had on
some level disconnected a bit from being
from being grateful
well you seem like you know a pretty I
mean I know you well enough to know
you're pretty grounded dude you know you
could be walking around like an entitled
prick you know there's plenty of people
in this town that do that
but you know I've seen you you know with
your family and you you just seem like
you exude that gratitude and you know I
think a byproduct of that is you know a
level of humility that I would have to
believe you know has been a bit of an
engine in perpetuating this you know the
longevity of the career that you've
enjoyed well I think you have to look
you you have to have self-confidence and
something particularly in in the art
world right you have to have
self-confidence and and and almost maybe
up to the edge you know of arrogance
because if you don't if you don't have
that strength if you don't have that
that that belief and that Drive then you
know what what is it
what what what is the thing that fuels
that hmm but when you also when you live
in the real world and you are subjected
to endless amounts of rejection and
until you kind of arrive at the place of
understanding that it's not personal
it's it's debilitating you know it's
really debilitating so how do you how do
you square that with yourself and I
think a lot of that is that it's those
it's the pause you know moments of
reflection where you can kind of go like
okay this is overwhelming this is over
you know I haven't booked a gig in three
months and my bank account is is almost
dry and I don't know if it's the laws of
attraction but I just know that when
you're in a positive place and you're
expressing gratitude those things tend
to I I don't know I'm you know I'm not
Hawaii gets Phil I'm not Einstein you
know I can't I wish I could solve the
problems of the cosmos but there's
I just feel that the gratitude and
humility are things that that attract
opportunity and success and the
important thing is that once you obtain
those things that you also have a
healthy respect of them but put them in
a place where they belong because it's I
have seen people who have achieved
tremendous success and they bear no
resemblance to the person that I knew
prior to that success and now I find
that heartbreaking because part of that
is yeah you have to have the humility
because if you if you get to a place of
success and people are whispering in
both ears about you know you can have
anything you want today da da da da da
the rules don't apply to you
the basic fundamentals of decency and
kindness those are the things that
really bother me when I when I see an
actor or you know air-quote here
celebrity being rude or acting entitled
it infuriates me particularly when
they're not talented because then I want
to say boy you should be exercising the
highest elbows I'm on the ground at a
time on the gratitude because you're
just lucky you're just lucky and I just
feel that that's you know it's really
the fuel minuul
a where 'no self-awareness but awareness
of the people around you you nave to be
an empath in order to kind of and it's
and it's hard because yeah you know we
do we get kind of hammered down with all
the stuff that we're dealing with with
paying our bills and and our health and
and so it's it's very easy to become
sort of dislodged by that and and sort
of thrown into the place of just you
know circling the drain of going what
what when when when
and and typically you know it's sort of
like you know on social media a lot of
times on Facebook you'll see people vent
about the you know and or you know post
about every single trespass yeah or you
know today I was at Starbucks and the
barista was rude and and and and then
the next day they go yeah I can't get an
agent you know i I've been I worked in
this business for ten years but I you
know I haven't had an agent for three
years I can't get an agent you know
what's where the industry is doing that
in and I don't need I always sort of go
you're just you're you're a magnet for
negative negativity that just be gets
more of that becomes a self-perpetuating
you know cycle of victimhood and blame
well years ago and that when when that
book in that video the power came out
and everybody was making fun of it oh
the secret you mean looking to see how
yeah and then then the power which came
afterwards I remember showing it to to
my mother my mother went okay I'll read
it and she read it and and she said you
know this is just the laws of attraction
the laws of attraction have been around
for a long time you know you can you can
manifest these things and she said so
it's not or it's not really a secret and
I remember being kind of taken aback by
that like you thought you were gonna
impart this drops of your mom's like
this is old news yes she kind of said
this is old news and a new wrapping she
said but it's not to discredit it
because she said I really think that you
know as a society we we gravitate
towards the negative so easily it
becomes it's so much easier to complain
than to about what we don't have then to
express gratitude for what we do have
and that landed on me in a big way and
it's not cool to be earnest about
positive things I know especially when
you're trying to be
badass in New York yeah and that doesn't
also that's the other thing that you
know you can always you can kind of spot
that in a 40-acre field you want to go
what are you so mad about you know
mm-hmm it's it's the same thing of
people making comments where you know
they'll say oh it must be nice and you
kind of go I'm sorry do I need to
apologize to you for working my ass off
well youyou got XY and Z social media is
always good for one of those guys yeah
you want to just say well you know what
I happen to have the filmstrip of my
life so look at chapters you know 3 6 9
all the way through to 17 and you can
see you know that journey it's you know
it's uh I don't know it becomes it sort
of you know it's like death you know
it's the price of admission I mean you
know there are just certain attitudes
and things that are productive and and
others that are that are
counterproductive yeah last thing I want
to ask you about which is kind of the
guiding principles for for living a
successful artists life you know
somebody's blazed this path for a long
time who grew up in that kind of
environment you know for people that are
listening who you know are pursuing some
kind of creative you know endeavor in
their lives like what are some of the
you know guideposts along the way that
have you know kept you true and that
have kind of you know empowered you
through the more difficult times I well
it goes back to gratitude but it also
it's it's self-reliance and I think with
ingratitude if you you have to find a
place to be able to be by be with
yourself and be and be happy with
yourself even in the mistakes that we
make but I I've always sort of repeated
this particularly to young actors that
to to achieve success and I mean you
know at the end of they what kind of
success
I mean what is it this success I mean do
you want to do you want to be famous if
you want to be famous go you know do
something and have your friends film and
they can post it on YouTube or be
infamous right and what you have to
define one has to define some level of
success Amin we all have to make a
living and pay our bills so you'd say
okay well that's you know I want to be
able to make a living but I think I
always say do this because you love it
because you have to do it because if a
person doesn't have to to be an actor if
it's not the thing that you're thinking
about dreaming about when you wake up
then do something else do find that
thing that that becomes your life force
that becomes your drive it's not just
because this whole idea of being you
know goals and being goal-oriented work
for certain things being goal oriented
as an artist is a fool's errand well
there's so little that you can control
because you can't control it right now
if you're if you're if you're running
and you're trying to beat a time or
something like that that's a whole
different thing so linear yeah but by
the same token we did help you're
cruising along and you step on a bad
pebble and you and you turn your leg now
you're out of business for a while I
think that it it's it's important to to
be passion and I'm sorry passions kind
of overused was to be to be really
focused and centered and truthful with
yourself am I doing this because it's
it's what I have to do because if it
isn't then do something else because
there's lots of other things to do and I
think many times people fall into the
into the arts for well a myriad of
different reasons
you know they they're they're the big
fish in the small pond in high school
plays and so
well I'm gonna be an actor or then they
get out into into a really big pond and
they realize that there are many many
more people that are as talented if not
more talented than they are and that's
not what should inform your decision
what should inform your decision is is
that commitment and and that passion and
then the rest of it is your head down
you know it's the teeth of a gale you've
got it because that's gonna be the thing
that at the end of the day it's gonna
move you past that place when it feels
hopeless and you when you haven't worked
or you can't get an agent so how do you
facilitate that well then you get
another job because you still have to
pay your bills so you know doing things
kind of willy-nilly you have to have
discipline in that way you do have to
have a plan you have to say okay if my
rent is X and my cable bill and my gas
is X then I've got to have a job that's
going to give me that and then enough
money for a little walking-around money
to do whatever yeah and the discipline
to weather the obstacles like if you
presume like presume an even playing
field between a couple different people
that are all equally talented and
equally passionate who are driven to do
this you know the obstacles are gonna
where some of those people down and
they're they do they're gonna they're
gonna be out they just the the person
that will prevail is the one who can
persistently continue to show up in the
face of all of that negative feedback
because they're driven by you know a
power source that it's more powerful
than that they can override that yeah I
look I mean there were people that I
went to NYU with it were staggeringly
talented actors really good people that
I respected and that inspired me and
there there is less than a handful of
those people who actually have gone on
to have successful careers you know it's
Hunter Thompson's
you know when the going gets weird the
weird term Pro and that's when that's
that's my that's my mantra you know yeah
when it gets weird do you you know
you've got to be weirder and and because
it's a all the all the other stuff that
comes along the accoutrements that
that's kind of fleeting at the end of
the end unless you're a complete
psychopath and a narcissist right now
I'd be less than truthful to say when a
person comes up to me on an airplane or
on the street and says that they really
enjoy a performance that I've that makes
me feel good right but I'm also you're
never gonna find me standing in JFK with
a Bosch hat waiting for sanity and the
deadwood t-shirt you know just kind of
looking around like anytime yeah
actually we should make that YouTube
video that would be good just have
people walk by no one's paying attention
to you you just got brought no it's
because that and the that at the end it
is it's the I always say sustenance but
that's what it that's what it feels like
you know when you when I come off of a
long day of shooting and yeah I am I am
I tired absolutely and when we finish
the season I'm exhausted but nothing
when I wake up in the morning I'm in a
good mood when I arrived on the set I
have a smile on my face no matter what
has happened because I know that I'm
going to get to do what I love to do and
there's it's a gift man there's nothing
more fulfilling and and and that's when
not only gratitude but tremendous joy
right even even particularly when it
sussed and I always joke I mean this is
this is my my way of kind of breaking it
up with a crew when you know we're into
our 15th 16th hour on on you know
which is now Saturday morning and
there's just that that kind of you know
grumbling hubbub of people just
exhausted and III say out of the blue
this show sucks okay and that will
always by buy us another three or four
hours because we all laugh because at
the end of the day it doesn't suck yeah
everybody knows that they're stoked to
be part of this thing we're all working
doing what we love to do and we don't
want to be doing anything else we want
to be doing that and we all care for
each other we all respect each other and
what are we doing we're we're
entertaining right we're entertaining or
we're making art and what a what a cool
way to to make a living to to do that
and so yeah this show sucks right it why
do you guys a great place to put a pin
in it this job does not say when do you
when you start shooting again August 1st
we go back in season 6 season 5 comes
April 19th very excited for that to come
out into the world I think it's not so
the other great thing about working with
this group of people despite the success
you know the critical success and all
that of the show no one has ever fell
back and it sort of rested on there
Laura mean each season you know you know
the the effort to choose the right book
to take it to the next level and to
raise the bar for ourselves because you
know Conley says we're only as good as
the challenges that we present for
ourselves which is true and and this
season is is gangbusters I'm really
proud of it and for the people who you
know the diehards who love the books and
love the show they'll they'll be well
rewarded for their patience because I
know it's a long wait so that that's
April 19 April 19th 19th coming up man
that's cool I want to come to the set
any that visit any time any time as you
get a hat and a t-shirt
I'll go to JFK and stand there you go
and we got to get you running again dude
yeah I know you know I know all right
we'll make it right after my next
cigarette yeah cool all right
Thank You Man thank you for great to
connect with you today I really
appreciate everybody man there's a lot
of fun that's the luck man thank you
brother peace peace
[Music]